I'M GOING TO JAIL !
Occasionally, we are blessed with a show
which upsets the natural order of things,
and oftentimes can change the way we view entire genres or a medium.
The original Mobile Suit Gundam revolutionized the way we saw mechas,
grounding it in a commentary of war and politics.
Akira opened up the door to international acclaim,
pushing the limits of what animation can do that stands to this day.
But today, I would like to bring attention to
a currently airing show which I feel is a classic in the making
that would change the landscape and would be
talked about for years to come
The masterpiece that is
Eromanga Sensei
*drops bag*
Masterfully disguised as the typical
fanservice harem show we've seen a million times every season,
one can easily assume that this is just another otaku bait
anime appealing to the lowest common denominator.
But the more I watched, the more I came to
the realization that Eromanga Sensei is a true masterpiece of our time.
Now, understandably, you may be skeptical with words
like "Masterpiece" being thrown around a lot these days,
but I assure you, those of us who understand can attest
to everything that this show has been able to achieve.
*creepy laugh*
Eromanga Sensei is the latest addition to the glorious
"Imouto" genre
which has seen a huge surge within anime in recent years
along with genres like the "Isekai" genre,
the "Slice of Life" genre and the
"Dear
"Dear god
"Dear god just
"Dear god just please
"Dear god just please kill it with fire" genre.
For those of you unaware, Imouto is the japanese name
given to the little
sss
ssss
sssss
ssssss
sssssss
ssssssss
sssssssss
ssssssssss
*inhales*
SSSSSSSSSSS
SSSSSSSSSSSS
SSSSSSSSSSSSS
SSSSSSSSSSSSSS
SSSSSSSSSSSSSSS
SSSSSSSSSSSSSSSS
SIS
SISTER
And the genre normally involves a focus on her and
her onii-chan which translated to English is basically
what she calls her
Fuck
Fuck Buddy
Coming from the same light novel author that wrote
the revolutionary "My Little Sister Can't Be This Cute,"
a show which everyone thought was going to be
the good old incest bait-and-switch only
to realize that the show was doing exactly
what it said on the fucking tin,
his latest work aims to push the boundary even further
on his eternal mission to alienate every sibling pair on Earth
and, possibly, the entire cosmos.
This time, it focuses on a young, light novel author
who discovers his shut-in little sister
*who's not related by blood*
was the famous erotic illustrator, Eromanga-sensei
who has been drawing the illustrations for him the entire time.
And, thus, we follow on our daily adventures
as our lead meets a bunch of other under-aged girls
who vie for his attention against his not-related-by-blood little sister.
*Did I mention the sister is not related by blood, 'cause that's really important*
Now, you may be asking yourself,
"How can such a series be considered a masterpiece?"
I mean, it just sounds like another super trashy show.
This is a common misconception, as Eromanga Sensei isn't just a trashy show.
High School DxD... is a trashy show.
High School of the Dead... is a trashy show.
Himouto! Umaru-chan... is a trashy show.
Eromanga-sensei is something else.
It is... an enigma that transcends the limits of trash itself to become something beyond.
A perfect car crash of garbage that takes the lowest common denominator
and divides that by zero.
This isn't just trash, it's a full-on fucking landfill
and, in doing so, has become the ultimate work of art.
Not all heroes wear capes, and not all art belongs in a gallery,
but if a urinal can be tastefully presented as an art piece,
then we must ask:
"Why can't we do the same with a loli saying, 'I love dick!'"
But, of course, not all art can be appreciated by everyone
which is why, to understand the full extent of this masterpiece,
one needs to fully accept who they really are.
In Buddhism, it is said that "The root of all suffering is attachment,"
and Eromanga Sensei has a similar mantra about it.
For, you see, it is this attachment you must first sever yourself from before you will be ready.
Appreciation can only be achieved once you let go of everything.
Self-esteem, shame, human decency, dignity, and any chance...
of your parents looking at you with pride.
You must dedicate years of your life enveloped in the world of anime,
and I'm not talking about good, well-written shows...
Fanservice, glorious jiggling tits, uncomfortable fetishes,
adorable anime girls becoming one with the idea of panty-shots.
Throw yourself off the deep end with no safety net to catch you,
as only once you have fully dedicated to this lifestyle
will you reach true enlightenment, and come to the realization
of the one, undeniable truth of this world...
Anime
Anime is
Anime is Trash
and so am I.
You see, to fully comprehend trash, you must first become it,
and once you have reached this higher(lower?) plane of degeneracy
will you begin to realize the miracle that has befallen us here
because... this is beyond what everyone thinks it is.
It's not really an incest show because they aren't related by blood
and that makes it totally acceptable.
And, you see, it's not this weird sexualization
of twelve year old lolis, because they're just anime characters
that don't even exist!
*Officer!*
Somehow, the show manages to keep topping itself every week
which is a testament to how revolutionary it is.
Every episode, you go in, thinking,
"There's NO WAY this show can go any lower!"
And then, against all odds,
it
it does...
See, while other shows may say, "Panty-shot Fanservice,"
Eromanga has the guts to say,
"Moe, loli, incest, siscon, bondage, panty-shot fanservice
with a dash of Ochin-chin."
If there was a single flaw in this show, it would be, probably, with the title.
"Eromanga Sensei" is short, relevant, and to-the-point,
but, with only two words, I think there is vast room for improvement
as this is nowhere near the recommended word count for a standard light novel title.
Some more suitable examples could've been:
"My Little Sister Can't Be This Cute But This Time She Draws Lewd Art And Is Twelve,"
"Surely There's No Possible Way We Could Make This Go Trashier Next Week, Right?"
or my personal favorite: "Fuck It. I Was Already Going To Hell."
This is not mentioning one of the greatest opening and ending sequences
to ever grace the world of anime.
And, no, it's not because of this expertly drawn calf muscle
but, of course, the Sagiri Dance.
Previous anime dances may have spread through this community
through a catchy, well-animated, choreographed dance,
but Eromanga Sensei asks,
"Why do you need to put all that effort in
when you can just wave your arms around like some kawaii twat?"
Oh, you know, it's whatever; maybe I'm overstating it.
I mean, it's just a cute girl waving her arms around at the end of the day, right?
It's not like I could watch this on repeat for hours or something.
You know, i-it's not, i-i-it's not that addicting.
I don't, I don't have a problem.
*opens door*
Sydsnap: Hey, I'm back, e-
*sigh*
I shoulda known.
I thought we were over this...
Gigguk: YOU JUST DON'T UNDERSTA-
Yet, somehow, against all odds, the show has somehow managed to dodge a "Best Girl War"
as we all have a mutual understanding of whoever we choose as best girl, we are all losers anyway.
I mean, we all know that Sagiri is going to win,
so what's the point of resisting that when we already have someone top tier?
Okay, maybe you're someone who thinks someone like Emilia is a good waifu,
and, if you do, that's completely fine!
I have the highest respect for garbage men and the work that they do,
but you have to ask yourself: "Is she a socially awkward, imouto loli
who draws lewd pictures, steals panties, and permanently sounds like she's doing ASMR?"
If the answer is "No," then that might be a sign for some self-reflection.
You think it ends here, but it goes even deeper
as episode 8 blows everything out of the water.
See, with a scene in this episode, we get a shot of Kuroneko,
confirming that the show indeed takes place in the same universe as Oreimo.
But we can also confirm that both Mahouka and Sword Art Online exist in some form, also, through references.
The implications of which are massive, as this could indicate the beginning of a franchise to rival Marvel itself.
Sagiri, Kirino, Miyuki, and Sugu could join together to create
the world's first "Imouto Cinematic Universe!"
WE'RE GETTING THE ICU, BABY!
As the ultimate appreciation of things only the Japanese can do,
see, the Japanese are absolute experts at creating these little inventions
you didn't know you needed until you saw them.
Just go into any Daiso and you'll see what I mean.
I didn't know a Pritt stick of butter would be something I wanted until I saw that.
A tie that doubles up as an umbrella would be hella useful for living in the UK,
and, until I saw Eromanga Sensei, I had no idea what I
needed in life was an adorable imouto to blush and call me "Baka!"
*Sagiri trembling*
*gasps* *gasps* "BAKAAAA!"
So, by now, you're hopefully more understanding of the masterpiece that is Eromanga Sensei.
A1 Pictures have absolutely outdone themselves, and I'm not sure of what they could possibly do
to get this work closer to perfection.
*clipboard slap*
Wait a minute, d-did they just add a t-tournament arc...
ssssssssssssssssssssssssss
TOUR-
In short, Eromanga Sensei is a masterpiece,
a show we only get once a generation,
which is why I can wholeheartedly say that we are witnessing this cultural revolution in action.
It's a show that reaches new heights of degeneracy,
trash that transcends the idea of trash,
and something that can only be admired by those few brave warriors
who have given up on everything.
In years past, we will look at this time as the redefining era,
or say: "The world was never the same after Eromanga Sensei.
Eromanga Sensei contributed to world peace.
Eromanga Sensei solved world hunger.
Eromanga Sensei isn't just cancer, Eromanga Sensei gave me cancer...
And then cured it...
And then gave me AIDS instead."
*in slow motion* "I'M GOING TO JAIL!"
Ending Song Lyrics: I--, I, I love little girls, they make me feel so good
I love... Little Girls, they make me feel so bad...